hello and welcome to see you're playing
motor home so going together Rui
continue to play a little bit of one
year for to do for something different
that way I got the Norwegian Norwegian
defense to the rib wow you don't see
that John what do you do me a castle I
go to cancel first maybe it's maybe de
force stronger I don't know yeah so
Queen cheeks three chicks i cannot
players are key know what rap but i
thought that i should have my vengeance
black doesn't develop anything else Oh
default cannot cannot be possibly bad I
mean this would be very strange okay Wow
flex development is a non-existing so
how to hard to do this rookie one is
going to go Bishop e7 I guess we should
be five also Bishop e7 I'm not sure
about it maybe Queenie to look the 15
that also threatens night XP five in
some cases
can walk you one next
what you find immediately if he goes
Knight f6 for example you five
immediately as a no is it move
27 Jim opposing the Queen iya should be
an idea so Knight f6 is e5 in some cases
95 is also possible okay long it's not a
move that I expected I want to do it
maybe just bishop to have 495 something
on 94 and then potentially sec on b5
still very very problematic for black
this position yeah so e5 it's going to
play Knight h5 I guess
and it doesn't do that much
yes weird stuff like Queen to g4
sometimes 9424 and I have to trade stuff
you really don't do what don't want to
do an owie 59 h5 Bishop h2 as possible
it's a bit of a lame move for age 308
okay and he's attacking a three-year
well
what a weird game
maybe we can even play this night h5
stuff well that you can afford it sits
on almost unbelievable
yeah i'm going to take on b5 next I
don't really care if it works or not but
I have to play the move
thirdly night a seminar any has to take
that night I don't really see any
alternative to that potential made on g2
is something that I have to be away also
cannot easily move my bishop here check
check okay so what's the deal here maybe
just back looks a little bit lame but I
think it's good just go back I am I can
take this six now just wonder how
exactly with this hook maybe with this
rook it takes the night as Queen to see
form which should be winning text the
Queen that XD 7 and looks at c7
black resigns yep so I don't know I mean
I really believe that this is an
incorrect opening for black but I'm not
totally sure how it is play it though
maybe d 4 immediately I'm already not
sure so this D fornix normal and now he
took it I think normally they take on b3
and and play this position yeah i'm not
sure i mean i just made made things up
here it I mean why tears like 310 p.m.
and castles that both nights out and
black also has some weaknesses so I have
a hard time to believe in this that
looks very logical 45 always and now
long castles i'm pretty sure that my
next moves are not ideal here and this
year h3 is a very lame move but my
original idea was of course e5 but after
night h5 I wasn't really sure that this
is doing me any good I was seeing this
line but age 3 spot y is h three mo
bishop jakes and then i take this ok and
then the end this night is trapped ok ok
ok this is what irritated me I thought
Quincy Forza is a very annoying move
with NAT f4 and Bishop e3 but h3 is good
ok so then I should play this and then I
should play this or or here again the
engine things that is that it is better
here black
95 hmm very unclear situation okay this
is probably too lame like here and now
he yeah 97 I don't believe I said simply
don't believe this I was expecting I
mean maybe black can take what I came
and six no probably not yeah but this is
this is I don't I don't believe it ID
426 the engine likes black and thinks
this isn't working just ate eggs be five
maybe maybe but I mean night XP five is
just a move you play in a blitz game
there's nothing much else to say about
it the engine believes that that can
simply take yeah maybe I was thinking
there might be something I mean the
queen is looking at this but I don't
have a good discovery it seems yeah so
that tech seems to be objectively
incorrect and Jackie now check I'm just
winning the house seems that sorry i
miss Channing quicker when Janet d check
this is supposed to be better Bishop
Jake's yeah probably because they're
sarouk a six-year coming and like this
as a forced made now according to the
company ok that's just taking stuff yet
this win pretty sure wide net yards plus
a level it's a very risky opening for
black even though we probably got away
with it technically speaking my attack
was not correct it seems okay well
thanks for watching